hello Co a family and the reject nation
it's Greg Alva and I'm John Humphrey so
right now on the real rejects channel it
is still active it extol exists but
since November 30th we have had zero
access to the channel cannot login at
this point it's become a joke hahaha
suppressing emotion it's pretty absurd
if you want more details and updates on
what's going on with the channel right
now you can go visit our Facebook page
facebook.com slash the real rejects
detail explanation we're working on
getting it back so don't worry in the
meantime my brother was so kind to let
us at least put up our Jurassic world
reaction on the Kawai Family Channel
thanks G Abby you're the bomb and really
quick before going into this I wanted to
say thank you to our sponsor Stardust
start us is this app that allows you to
do 30 second reactions for any film TV
show or trailer even though the channel
is up we still got videos there we're
providing new videos and start us right
now so it gives us something to do even
put it one up for Jurassic world there's
probably been 104 Jurassic world 2 right
now anyway follow us there in the
meantime we'll get the channel back in
our hands very soon making progress
anyway enough beating around the tushy
let's watch this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I know I were here a rescue op save the
dinosaurs island that's about to explode
[Music]
what could go
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what are they running from volcano
everything
that'll keep them safe whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every problem people have had with the
Jurassic world movie they have ant all
the problems embracing it's so much the
other problem people have with it I've
been saying it that's why I enjoyed it
cuz it's just a Rock'em Sock'em
ridiculous monster fest and they've
amped up the ridiculousness even more if
you thought Chris Pratt talking with
Raptors was stupid well it's gonna get
stupider thought them out running
craziness was stupid it's gonna get even
dumber right now if you thought then
being a little ball thing keeping them
safe in the first movie was dumb well
it's gonna be even dumber
I thought they were gonna go alright you
know what we got a little carried away
with the first one we heard some
complaints maybe we'll die back but then
we made over a billion dollars they're
just gonna amp it up to the whole other
level Chris Pratt out running everything
while they're in the ball it's so insane
it's insane this movie yeah that's kind
of a funny approach to take I mean I
feel like that almost could work I mean
this trailer took me aback but kind of
engrossed me at the same time because
you know hey it's better than
retroactive continuity I guess doubling
down yeah and the previous thing so
maybe it can be a hundred percent its
own just knowing what the material is
now and what it's become even having
that a little homage or Jeff Goldblum
being in there for a brief second I
don't think he's gonna show up on the
island I really feel like especially
with Jurassic world it's become much
more of a science fiction movie dress
where it's always been sci-fi I know
that I'm saying that the world
world is sign now it looks like an
action/adventure in terms of sci-fi you
know they're having oh the dinosaurs
they have to go there and help save them
because these animals are in danger of
being extinct again are they sending
Bryce how it down is how to do that
should know anything about dinosaurs
doesn't matter that's what makes this so
beautiful and all the right awful ways
why would you send two people and a kid
on this mission
I don't know drastic world part one
dealt with dinosaur hybrid and now this
is dealing with saving animals from
extinction it's to it but it's not it's
not actually about that it's that world
kind of way it's not about any of those
things it's just about action and
adventure and having a total blast
e-blast it does look cool and J Bayona
like that dude is a sharp director who
can bring tension and can bring actions
yeah in that regard I feel like
especially with him in the director's
chair probably be thrilling and fun and
G which is probably all I want from this
right now and even getting the t-rex to
work would have at the end of that
moment when it saves them oh my god they
have really reinvented this fragile what
what fast v was to The Fast and the
Furious not saying it fast in the ferris
was a great movie or a Fast Five is it
exceptionally great movie
that's what I kind of feel like they've
done with this is they've just waited
some cheesy hyper intense action flick
with dinosaurs and ridiculousness and
through the roof and one thing you got
to give it credit for and how I feel
like this is its own new trilogy is
they're actually taking the main
characters from the first one drastic
world and bringing them back as opposed
to the second one just had Jeff Goldblum
then the third one had Sam Neill this
one you're like no I gave Bry stop
they're continuing it with these
characters who you could really care
less about yeah I don't know I'm
actually pleasantly surprised that it's
wow it's it's just as but actually more
ridiculous
yeah I had fun like I said I felt all
the things watching this trailer and
it's weird because it's not different
from anything I expected and that means
many different things to me in that
moment half of me is like this can be a
lot of fun half of me is like what is
this you know the other half is other
that was a total blast e-blast to sum up
our thoughts here's what we said on the
Stardust app that we are filming after
this but due to editing we could put it
in
now guys this trailer was ridiculous
everything that people had issues with
about how this franchise has been
reinvented with talking to Raptors t-rex
is helping out the ball sphere thing
helping you survive all the dodging and
avoiding running away from dinosaurs a
catastrophe
they have amped it up to a whole other
level Jeff Goldblum in here kind of cool
I guess but everything is so
ridiculously cheesy and I love it to be
honest I enjoy that song as it goes
Jurassic Park but I like it once again
guys we have made a lot of progress or
getting logged back in to our channel so
thank-you Jabby in the meantime for
letting us put this one video up on your
channel you are very kind and you are
the better-looking brother between you
and John so thank you so much subscribe
to the real rejects we'll have videos
code have forgetten very soon and
subscribe to the co a family jab eco a
he makes awesome content and has some
hot-ass ladies on here too
make sure to check us out on the
stardust app and also become a patron
eject today there's where we can upload
daily and all the YouTube videos that we
have shot and edited that haven't had
the chance to go up on our channel yet
they're all going up there on our
patreon for the lowest pledge possible
which is just the $1 tier so go
followings now don't you